let's get more on the junior doctor
strikes just announced a 72 hour walkout
next month as that pay dispute rumbles
on Dr vasili crispy is the co-chair of
the Yorkshire Junior doctors committee
at the British Medical Association and
joins us now hello thanks for joining us
on the program this morning good morning
uh so good morning another good morning
another strike by Junior doctors why
well since the first two industrial
action have finally brought the
government to the table and we'll be
negotiating for the past three weeks we
believe we'll now reach a point where
talks are no longer productive the
government have failed to legitimize our
claim for a 26 pay erosion in the past
15 years and we've been given an offer
of five percent which doesn't go far
enough to recognize the pay erosion let
alone cover the and match the inflation
for the past 12 months it is not a
credible offer and that's why we're once
again using our mandate in order to show
the government the Resolute in our
dispute
the strikes are called off
what the government have already got
another meeting schedule with us
tomorrow with Mr Barkley coming around
the table and we're hoping for him to
finally bring that credible offer on the
table for us to consider and potentially
put all my our members we already see
looking across the border that the
Scottish government have gone far to
begin with in order to negotiate an
initial offer which England simply are
not doing
uh so sorry just to be clear is that
meeting still going ahead then
as far as I'm aware yes that meeting is
you're going a hat uh because the um the
government I think you might be in for
quite a nasty surprise the government's
saying no they're not talking to you
until you call off
um any more strikes
well in that instance the government
must recognize that we still have a
strong mandate our fellow colleagues are
still leaving the country to work in
other professions and in other countries
all together and we're still at a
breaking point five percent in US is not
a credible offer that we can put to
members he doesn't recognize the pain
the inflation that we already suffered
this year it is simply not acceptable
yeah but uh unless you call the strikes
off they're not going to talk to you so
you're going to call the strikes off
no we will not be calling the strikes
off and we already know that if the
government is not willing to come back
to the table and then negotiated with us
will be striking regularly throughout
the summer we've got a strong Resolute
we have a strong mandate doctors are at
a Breaking Point as we already discussed
plenty of times beforehand and the
government must realize that the fact
that a thing to acknowledge the 26 pay
erosion the very basic of our dispute is
actually offending to our profession
soon it could be illegal for you to
strike
what we have already announced that we
will be moving forward towards rebound
team of course with no announced at
eight or when this is going to this is
going to be however throughout the rest
of our mandate we're hoping to be able
to renew this in order to show our
strong position in order to continue
negotiation we continue to want to meet
at the table and we've always sent to
negotiations in good faith however now
that talks have reached a point of no
longer being productive a five percent
offer is not credible we're just hoping
that the government do realize that
we're still here for a fight we're still
fighting for our profession for the NHS
and for our patients and therefore they
must bring a credible office on the
table otherwise colleagues will continue
to leave the country and the
professional together
but my point is that soon it could be
illegal for doctors to strike
well when we're looking at the empty
strong build this does not factors at
present in the first instance and what
we have already seen is that we're
relying on other colleagues within our
profession especially doctors and
Consultants to provide a safe minimum
coverage for emergency care that
patients do need therefore Gene doctors
will likely be able to continue to
strike in the first instance but the
reality is that bringing forward an
anti-strike bill in order to prohibit
public to from exercising their right to
strike is not the solution to the
problem the solution will be to properly
address the pay erosion that we've all
suffered across the health the health
sector and the public sector for decades
now for prohibiting from striking is not
the answer so that we want to meet
around the table in order to discuss
this further